acting offensively or just plain bad at
acting live from New York it's Saturday
night and these celebrities aren't
invited in 1990 Sinead O'Connor was at
the peak of Fame and success following
the release of her smash hit single
nothing compares to you O'Connor
nevertheless boycotted a Saturday Night
Live appearance when the show booked
controversial comedian Andrew Dice Clay
to host O'Connor finally ended up
performing on SNL in October 1992
delivering a haunting and riveting
acapella take on Bob Marley's War at the
end of the song O'Connor provided what's
likely the most infamous moment in
Saturday Night Live history she
lambasted Pope John Paul II by holding
up a picture of the pontiff and ripping
it up
fight the Real Enemy
SNL director Dave Wilson made sure the
Applause sign stayed dark and the show
Cuts commercial emits Stony quiet
meanwhile chaos ensued in the studio
while operators fielded calls from
numerous angry viewers an audience
member tried to assault O'Connor and had
to be removed by security unsurprisingly
O'Connor never played SNL ever again
the man they call yay has appeared as
the musical guest on Saturday Night Live
seven times and has typically turned in
performances as inspired as his
critically acclaimed albums not content
to just stand on stage in rap Kanye West
brings his own bespoke sets light shows
special effects and even costumes when
he and Lil pump performed I love it on a
September 2018 episode they did so in
gigantic silly movement impairing water
bottle costumes West was held in such
high regard that SNL producers allowed
him a rare third performance segment in
that particular episode uh-oh Kanye got
that look oh no what are you up to Kanye
oh he's definitely gonna do something
rather than merely play a song however
West delivered an off-the-cuff speech in
Praise of President Donald Trump while
wearing one of the politicians signature
make America great again hats NBC cut
the speech short for viewers as SNL's
90-minute time slot had run out
nevertheless West continued to walk
around the stage and wax political
claiming to have been bullied backstage
for wearing a mega cap criticizing the
mainstream media and dismissing
allegations of racism Levy to Trump all
this prompted booze and led host Adam
Driver and cast member Chris Redd to
walk off not long after West claimed on
Twitter that SNL producer Lauren
Michaels had asked him to return as a
host according to Radar Online though
West's Antics led to quite the opposite
a ban from the series
Martin Lawrence was one of the most
famous and popular stand-up comedians of
the early 90s Not only was he host of
HBO's deaf Comedy Jam but he also
co-created and played multiple roles on
Fox's smash hit sitcom Martin during the
peak of Martin Mania in February 1994
Lawrence was invited to host Saturday
Night Live as his customary four
stand-up comics hosting the program
Lawrence's show opening monologue was a
comedy routine which proved just as edgy
profane and eyebrow raising as one from
Lawrence's successful stage act after
joking about the Lorena Baba case the
comedian went on a run about his
first-hand experiences with feminine
hygiene or black thereof when the
episode aired later that night for West
Coast viewers NBC cut that portion of
the monologue and replaced it with a
black screen explaining the gist of
Lawrence's commentary claiming that
Network policy prevents any rebroadcast
of the routine
sisters of follow me everywhere around
which they get off my ass oops damn did
I slip you the episode went on as
scheduled but Network Executives banned
Lawrence afterward and apparently not
just from appearing on SNL ever again
but from the entirety of NBC Lawrence
has returned to the peacock for a number
of appearances on The Tonight Show but
he's still never been back to Saturday
Night Live
genre bending musical iconoclast Frank
Zappa never took himself too seriously
often infusing his music with his
signature sense of offbeat humor that's
why he seemed like a good bet for
Saturday Night Live and the show hired
him to do double duty as both host and
musical guest for an episode in October
1978. instead of a chill time however
this episode became according to SNL
writer and performer Don novello quote
one of the worst ever Novella recalled
that the episode's final dress rehearsal
before the live broadcast went horribly
which unnerved Zappa he explained we had
a terrible dress and what was he going
to do what he did not telling anybody
was he turned into Dean Martin that
meant that Zappa decided to act
self-aware trying to express to the TV
viewing audience the irony and artifice
of scripted television Novella
elaborated he read the cue cards like he
was reading the cards he made a point of
it that was his approach to the humor no
one else in the sketches knew it
[Music]
thank you and remember I'm reading this
off these cards underneath this camera
here thank you Lauren Michaels didn't
care for Zappa's unauthorized take on
the material so he permanently prevented
the rock star from ever returning to SNL
early SNL fancied itself an edgy
youthful show and so it's 1997 holiday
episode featured Punk adjacent new
waiver Elvis Costello as the musical
guest in his first slot he played
watching the detectives in a fun yet
generally unremarkable segment in his
second slot though Costello got just a
few seconds into less than zero before
changing his mind
I'm sorry ladies and gentlemen there's
no reason to do this song here
[Music]
and played his
radio radio in its entirety not only is
that song viciously critical of mass
media but Costello had been told by
Lauren Michaels specifically not to play
it he did anyway and promptly got banned
from the show as a result Michael's
apparently had a change of heart because
he allowed Costello to come back to SNL
in March 1989 to perform a couple of
songs off his album spike it all came
full circle a decade later when Costello
made fun of himself and the incident
that led to his ban on the SNL 25th
anniversary show The Beastie Boys played
sabotage for a few bars until Costello
stormed out on stage and grabbed a
microphone
[Music]
I'm sorry ladies and gentlemen but
there's just really no reason to do this
song here tonight after that he and the
beasties launched into a rollicking
version of radio radio
sometime in the 1980s Saturday Night
Live established a show format that it
almost never Strays from comedy sketches
a monologue Weekend Update and two
musical performances from a single
Entertainer in its early days however it
was much more of a variety show for
instance the first episode from October
1975 had two musical guests three
stand-up routines from George Carlin a
Muppets segment and a performance by the
difficult to categorize Andy Kaufman
Kaufman's first bit was simple yet
bizarre he played the Mighty Mouse theme
song Only lip syncing to a single line
the exposure helped to make Kaufman a
sensation and found a larger audience
for his alt comedy and anti-comedy bits
including wrestling matches with women
and Elvis impersonations Kaufman
appeared on the shows in the late 70s
and early 80s but his most audacious bit
would also be his final one and he never
even showed up for it in a 1982 episode
SNL Producer Dick ebersol read a
statement on air explaining that
Kaufman's schedule appear had been
canceled and in my opinion Andy Kaufman
is not funny anymore and I believe you
the audience here agree with me viewers
at home were offered the chance to
decide Kaufman's fate voting on whether
or not to ban him from SNL Forever by
calling telephone hotlines dump ending
one out and Kaufman stop performing on
the show until his death two years later
in 1984.
after starring as polish Jewish musician
body slav Spielman in the harrowing 2002
drama of The Pianist Adrian Brody found
himself on the fast track to fame at the
2003 Academy Awards he beat out
luminaries such as Michael Caine Daniel
Day Lewis and Jack Nicholson for the
best actor Oscar then aggressively
kissed presenter Halle Berry on stage
without her consent his Newfound
celebrity status and his problematic
sense of humor was confirmed when he got
to host a May 2003 episode of Saturday
Night Live one of the hosts duties is to
introduce the evening's musical guest
and in Brody's case that was Jamaican
singer Sean Paul Brody took it upon
himself to grab a dreadlock wig and
ramble in an offensive Jamaican Patois
for nearly a minute before throwing it
back to Paul
Brody can't come back to SNL now but not
so much for his reggae inspired Antics
the bigger problem at least to Lauren
Michaels was that he improvised and thus
wasted time on the intricately planned
live television series
free over-the-air broadcast network
subject to the rules of content
restrictions imposed by the Federal
Communications Commission a live TV show
like Saturday Night Live carries with it
the risk that someone might say a curse
word bringing criticism and fines to the
network in 2005 SNL invited the metal
band a System of a Down to be its
musical guest on an episode hosted by
Johnny Knoxville during the group's
performance of its hit BYOB singer Serge
Tankian uttered the song's chorus in
full several times which included a few
f-bombs NBC's censor was quick with the
mute button successfully cutting to
silence each time tankin dropped one but
then System of a Down guitarist Darren
malikian stepped up to the mic and
caught up in the moment he yelled out an
impromptu shout of yeah according to
Entertainment Weekly NBC didn't receive
any messages from upset SNL viewers in
the days following the broadcast still
the company released a statement
acknowledging the profanity pointing the
fingers squarely at System of a Down For
What they referred to as an unsolicitive
expletive bassist Chavo odajian later
told K-Rock that the incident earned his
bend a ban from SNL still in effect as
of 2022. an April 1996 episode of
Saturday Night Live offered what Rage
Against the Machine guitarist Tom
Morello called an ironic juxtaposition
of host and musical guest marilla's band
a leftist revolutionary rap metal outfit
shared the bill with Republican
presidential candidate and billionaire
Steve Forbes there to promote their
latest album evil empire rage was
supposed to play two songs they wound up
performing just once the band set
decoration at the time included American
flags hung upside down a symbol that
indicates a nation under duress after a
sound check earlier on Saturday the band
was ordered by SNL Personnel to remove
the flags so as to not potentially upset
advertisers they complied but a minute
before the band's live performance
Roadies restored the flags and a stage
manager again ordered their removal
their crew guys go to take and we've
informed our crew guys defend the flags
defend the flags the band's Associates
and the SNL crew nearly came to blows as
the flags came down Mir seconds before
Forbes introduced rage live on TV after
the song rage bassist Tim Comerford took
one of the offending Flags tore it to
shreds balled it up and threw it into
Forbes dressing room moments later an
SNL employee escorted the band out of
the building quite permanently
by 1981 John Belushi Saturday night
Live's biggest breakout star at the time
had left the show for a movie career
he'd already starred in the mega hit
Animal House and agreed to star in the
dark comedy neighbors around that time
he got really into a loud angry and
chaotic punk band called fear and
befriended lead singer Lee Ving to the
point where they recorded a song for
Neighbors together producers who didn't
want a hardcore punk song on the
soundtrack of their mainstream movie
rejected it so blue she made it up to
fear by convincing SNL head Producer
Dick ebersold to book the band as the
musical guest for the Halloween 1981
episode fear brought volumes of
authentic Punk energy to the network
variety series but this wasn't
completely a good thing Fierce act
included film footage of bleeding
jack-o-lanterns and a bunch of violent
slam dancers neither of which was
anticipated by producers the show
actually cut off the live feed of fear
who kept playing and tearing up the
stage in the studio while viewers at
home saw a pre-taped Eddie Murphy sketch
the band left with about two thousand
five hundred dollars worth of damage in
its wake and a permanent ban from SNL
[Music]